Those in the know already know
Pokemon is a shortened name
for the "Pokemon" games'
main characters,
pocket monsters.
The infamous "gotta
catch 'em all" catchphrase
is the anglicized
interpretation of
the Japanese getto suru,
which more directly translates
to "getting," the main
objective of the game.
Through open-world exploration,
trade, and battling,
you play as a trainer
trying to collect, nurture,
and evolve as many
Pokemon as you can.
These fantastical creatures
exist as sentient beings
somewhere between wild
animal and beloved pet.
Monsters that are collected
in stored in Poke Balls,
Inspired by gachapon balls,
round plastic containers
used to house small collectible
items in vending machines,
the contraptions serve
as storage containers
and presumably mini bio-domes.
The Pokemon are inspired
by flora and fauna,
science, religion, yokai, and
other supernatural beings.
But the series is teaming with
not just Japanese folklore
but versions of monsters
from across the globe,
made cute with
softened features.
Quite a few
of the "Monstrum" monsters
have Pokemon counterparts,
like the golem,
Yuki Onna, Godzilla,
Mothra, banshees,
hellhounds, monstrous
plants, and kasha.
The bond between
Pokemon and trainer,
monster and human, is
one built on trust,
loyalty, and
reciprocal benefits.
In this way, Pokemon
distinguish themselves
from other monsters.
While there are monsters who
may show kindness to humans
or provide protection,
they still use fear
if not in behavior,
at least in appearance.
Nintendo didn't think
"Pokemon" would do well
with the Japanese audience,
let alone a global one.
They didn't even put any
promotion behind the first game.
So what changed?
Why did pocket monsters
become so freakishly popular?
[dramatic music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
"Pokemon" changed
the monster genre
by making monsters
cute, not scary,
capitalizing on already popular
monster consumer culture.
The first "Pokemon" game
for Nintendo's Game Boy
launched in Japan in 1996,
with a 10-year-old protagonist
and 151 creatures to
discover, catch, train,
and battle against one another.
The "Pokemon" game would
become a global phenomenon,
evolving into a card game,
multiple anime series, movies,
and a seemingly endless
barrage of consumer goods
like plush toys, makeup,
clothing, and more games.
With Japan's intense focus
on education, long commutes,
and jam-packed schedules,
"Pokemon" offered children
a portable and
communal space for play
that was accessible
and pleasantly distracting.
The game's inventor,
Satoshi Tajiri,
was mentored by one
of Nintendo's greats,
Shigeru Miyamoto,
video-game designer
and inventor of Mario.
Tajiri wove his own childhood
into part of
the "Pokemon" mythos.
Spending much
of his childhood outside,
Tajiri was an avid
collector of bugs,
tadpoles, and other
small creatures.
Most kids are.
I remember a time I brought
a frog into the house
with a leach attached to it,
a two-for-one catch
I couldn't wait to show off.
My mom was not so thrilled.
Come to think of it, that combo
might make a cool Pokemon.
We wouldn't have "Pokemon"
if it wasn't for Japan's
dense, eclectic,
and vast folklore.
Influenced and inspired in part
by polytheistic belief systems,
the yokai tradition gives
us some of the world's
most unusual and unusually
specific monstrous creatures,
and there is a long history
of collecting and profiting
from depictions of these
strange and supernatural beings.
Yokai-themed card games didn't
even begin with "Pokemon."
Hundreds of years before,
in the Edo period,
yokai-themed karuta, decorated
paper or cardboard cards,
were all the rage.
Towards the end of
the 19th century,
these cards were immensely
popular with children
who collected the
game cards with vigor.
In part because of the boom
of yokai consumer goods
like these, 19th-century
Japanese philosopher
Enryo Inoue was afraid
the deep folkloric history
of the strange creatures
would prevent the success
of industrialism and hinder
Japan's journey to modernity,
so he invented anthropological
system called Yokaigaku
that cataloged
and debunked yokai stories.
Ironically,
his detailed accounts
have helped preserve yokai lore.
19th-century Japan also
produced the first manga comics.
Prolific artists
Hokusai is credited
with naming this
particular style of art--
entertaining, whimsical
pictures that honored
existing Japanese
illustration traditions
while incorporating European
style-cartooning elements.
Respected manga
artist Shigeru Mizuki
is credited with reviving
popular interest in yokai.
In 1960, his series
"Hakaba Kitaro,"
which follows a young boy's
encounters with various yokai,
was deemed
too scary for children,
but of course, that did
not stop its popularity.
The playful plots
promoted harmony
between humans and yokai,
a message with a long
tradition in Japan.
It was also in the
20th century that another part
of "Pokemon's" unique
heritage was born: kaiju.
The giant monster film genre
began in 1954 with "Gojira,"
you can learn more
about that here,
and was immediately popular,
remaining a mainstay of
Japanese cinema to this day.
Saburo Ishizuki
produced the first
vinyl collectible
kaiju figurines,
notably cuter than their
onscreen predecessors.
They merged the
cute with the scary
and created tiny consumers
hellbent on holding
their favorite characters
in their own hands.
Seeing a kaiju battle
onscreen was cool enough,
but getting the chance
to recreate that scene
or better yet, create your
very own with your friends?
Now that is epic.
Illustrated Kaiju guidebooks
which I can't help but see
as the modern homage
to medieval bestiaries,
gave more details and background
stories to the characters.
"Pokemon" would adopt
something similar
with the Pokedex,
a digital bestiary.
This brings us to the tech
side of "Pokemon" lore.
Matt Alt author of
"Pure Invention:
How Japan Made
the Modern World,"
argues that the
success of the game
comes as a result of decades
of positive marketing
of influential toys and
consumer electronics
to the American market
that began in the 1950s.
"Pac-Man" took video
games from the arcade
into the supermarkets,
schools, and homes in 1980.
Then in 1989,
the release of Game Boy
meant that anyone anywhere
could play video games,
a massive market shift.
Nintendo was ready
to dominate and exploit.
Nintendo launched Tajiri's
relatively simple "Pokemon" game
in 1996 when they
were giving up hope
on the longevity
of the Game Boy.
The game was produced
with an unusual
and frankly genius feature.
Released in two cartridges,
"Pokemon Red"
and "Pokemon Green,"
you had to trade with another
player to collect them all
since 11 of the original
151 pocket monsters
would only evolve after trading,
an intentional design
choice by Tajiri,
who aimed to promote
social connection
in the real world.
It was this game design
strategy that continues
to work for the franchise today.
Each iteration of the game
contains unique Pokemon
and badges that can only
be collected by playing
and purchasing both
versions of the release.
Hell, I have "Pokemon Diamond"
and "Pokemon Pearl"
sitting in my Switch
carrier right now.
As "Pokemon" sales
began to climb in Japan,
Nintendo decided to capitalize
on the growing popularity.
A manga comic featuring
the cute monsters
was quickly produced
and published
in one of the most popular
magazines for young boys.
An anime followed
the next spring in 1997,
and then the first
big screen film.
It was virtually
impossible to escape
the game's presence
in Japanese culture,
and its popularity
kept expanding.
The game and
its various products
were released
in East Asia in 1997.
Part of the franchise's success
was its ability to appeal
to all genders
and a far wider age range
than previously
believed possible.
And a big part of that appeal?
Pikachu.
While many Pokemon
are undeniably cute,
with large eyes, expressive
faces, and exaggerated features,
they create strong emotional
attachments with consumers
when placed in narratives
in the anime and manga,
contributing to their
perception as kawaii.
Kawaii means more
than just cute.
It's really a cultural
touchstone
that began in the 1970s.
Something is kawaii only
if its cute, soft, round,
childlike features
are complimented
by their sweet and
gentle attributes.
One of the anime's
creators, Masakazu Kubo,
has said that the original
anime's target demographic
was young girls and mothers.
Remember, the original
Nintendo game's graphics
were far simpler than
what they are today.
It's difficult to show
cute in eight bit,
so which Pokemon could make the
leap from the console screen
and into the hearts
of the massive?
It's Pikachu.
Chosen for its bright,
non-aggressive color,
easy-to-say name,
sweet, expressive face,
and memorable,
cuddly silhouette,
Pikachu became a global icon
akin to Mickey Mouse
or Hello Kitty.
"Pokemon" first appeared to
American audiences in 1998,
as "Pokemon Red version"
and "Pokemon Blue version."
By 1999, the series
had earned $5 billion.
Kids across the world
couldn't get enough.
I was one of those kids.
I collected the cards
religiously and meticulously,
organizing my binder at school,
on the bus, and at home.
I carried that thing
to my friend's houses
where we would trade cards
with no intention
of playing the game.
For me, it wasn't
just about finding
an elusive holographic
or balancing my stats.
I simply loved looking
at the pictures
and learning
the monster's traits.
I guess in a way, I never
stopped being that little girl.
My monster collecting
just looks different now.
Monsters aren't the only
core appeal of "Pokemon."
It feeds that urge to
explore the outdoors
at a scale few could
achieve in real life.
It doesn't matter
if you were a kid
in an apartment high-rise
or an adult
trapped in a subway
commuting to work.
Rain or shine, come hell
or a dying battery life,
it allows you to
organically experience
a colorful, diverse natural
world, with the added bonus
of a seemingly unending
array of wild animals
or better yet, monsters
you get to keep as pets.
The protagonist of the first
"Pokemon" game and anime
is named after the
game's creator, Satoshi.
In English, he is called Ash.
He and the Pokemon
professors, Oak, Elm, Birch,
Rowan, Juniper,
Sycamore, and Magnolia,
emphasize the
importance of nature
as an instructive,
respected tool.
Viewed from an
environmentally friendly lens,
the game teaches players
to respect nature
and its inhabitants
as living creatures
integral to biodiversity,
not simple commodities.
Not all interpretations of
the game are so positive.
Some naysayers and
critics will argue
that Pokemon encourages
children to not only
feel familiar with conflict,
but seek it out,
citing the franchise's
battle elements.
Others claim that
capturing and trading
wild Pokemon animals
promotes hunting
or the mistreatment of
nature, where value is placed
on how they can work
for or fight for humans.
The staunchest of critics
will even point out
that trapping Pokemon, then
transporting them to trade,
where they might end up
as laborers or fighters,
has some problematic connections
to colonial history and slavery.
Debates about these
interpretations
have been going on pretty
much since "Pokemon" emerged
on the global marketplace.
Despite controversy,
the game's lingering impact
cannot be denied.
There are now over
1,000 types of Pokemon,
and the franchise is
stronger than ever.
The launch of
"Pokemon Go" in 2016
broke gaming barriers again.
That became the most downloaded
smartphone game in history,
reaching 21 million users only
two weeks after its launch
in the U.S., with 40% of those
users over the age of 25.
Tajiri's original
intent is honored
with this next evolution,
encouraging players to
interact with one another
outside of the
insular gaming bubble.
"Pokemon Go" is
a universal game you can play
from your phone literally
anywhere in the world.
It requires going
outside, moving around,
and often interacting
with others,
promoting physical
and mental health.
I've always believed that
monsters have the potential
to unite us, a way for us
to understand the lives
of other people and
better know ourselves.
While folklore and oral
storytelling began that trend,
with each new
communication technology,
we've long profited
from monsters,
socially and commercially.
"Pokemon's" heritage places it
within the realm of
national identity,
reflecting and influencing
Japan's cultural,
religious, social,
and environmental ideals.
Globalization widens
this worldview,
introducing Japanese history
into an unexpected
mainstream global context.
"Pokemon" just further proves
what I've always known:
monsters are meant to be shared.
I wanted to catch it.
No, 'cause now it's gone.
The main objective of
the game-- [laughing]
Pocket monsters.
My eight-year-old self
would be so proud.
Cut.